[Music]
he's no longer with us
and it's kind of suspicious so should we
really be saying
r.i.p to john mcafee the legendary
eccentric tech entrepreneur
was found dead in his prison cell
outside barcelona in what authorities
are calling an apparent suicide
no word on whether the authority who
said this is named hillary clinton
[Laughter]
mcavee who made his fortune creating
mcafee antivirus software was being
charged with tax evasion and just hours
before his death
a spanish court had approved his
extradition back to the u.s
which could explain the surprising
suicide maybe they were planning to fly
him back on
spirit airlines
now i trust everything the media says
with every cell in my body but what if
there was more to the story the
circumstances surrounding mcafee's death
are so fishy they came with a side of
chips and tartar sauce
he spoke for years about being a hunted
man and that the charges against him
were politically motivated
after what happened to jeffrey epstein
in his prison cell
would it really be surprising to learn
that mcafee didn't kill himself
could he have faked his own death leave
it to a brilliant jet-setting bitcoin
mogul to pull it off
now for legal reasons i'm not saying
he's still alive or that he was murdered
i'll let cat do that
but it's like steve ducey used to say
when we'd go camping
if there's no body there's no crime
[Laughter]
all right cat you met and talked to him
i did how long ago
and you we've seen back when you live
libertarian you're going to say when i
was in my 40s or something like that
right yes you know whenever you make fun
of me for being old you're much older
than i am
you are aging as a man but still yeah
but i age gracefully
oh i i age very gracefully all right
let's get back
so yeah alive or dead i bummed a
cigarette from this guy at the
libertarian convention in 2016. and we
talked for 15 minutes and it was truly
like i've been like i i've been bored
every second of my life compared to that
no offense that's almost as insulting
but no because this guy you people have
this thing
most people have this thing in their
brains where they think a little bit
before they talk
he not even the slightest bit i mean
what some call
tax evasion he says listen i'm just
running from these people trying to
steal from me
he was like i don't believe in taxes so
nothing would surprise me when it comes
to this guy i mean he was truly just
like
did not care you can't judge him among
a standard of what humans are like
because he was nothing like that yeah
you know um if one there's one person
besides mike baker who can fake their
own death
it's this guy i mean the guy had he had
he had bitcoin
he had bitcoin he knew a lot of people
he was cunning
what's your what's your take i haven't
seen the body
well yeah i know and that's always it
right there and we know epstein didn't
kill himself let's be honest so yeah
that's that
anybody who still thinks he does or did
yeah uh well
greg as you know uh i'm right in the
middle of filming the second season of
discovery
uh hit series uh black follows
declassified
yes in black foster classified uh he
turns to the audience and looks at them
and smiles
um we do a lot of investigations right
and
that plus my time with the agency over
all those years has taught me that
a lot of times things are just as easy
as they seem or just as simple as they
seem
and but in this case um
yeah you had a guy who was slipping into
paranoia right and over a period of time
you had a guy whose health was was uh
was diminishing over a period of time
um you had a guy who was fearful of
coming to the states
of actually having this extradition you
killed him so
no i'm not saying that uh i'm not i'm
not saying that
you didn't yeah i'm not saying i didn't
i'm not saying that but but uh
i i i'm not a i'm not a conspiracy guy
much like you you're not a conspiracy
guy
conspiracy that's why this is
interesting to me yeah i
think anything you're saying i don't
know but i'm just saying i think
i don't think i don't think he's alive
still do i think he killed himself
or was he possibly killed in prison uh
one or the other okay all right thank
you thank you that
yeah he killed him walter
you are i am a conspiracy theorist yes
when i was younger i used to start with
what nbc news told me and then i'd work
toward the weird
now i start with the weird and go back
to what nbc news tells me
my default position is that everything
is crazy
uh ufos are about to land um and we
shouldn't trust anyone
uh in this case i think he went nuts and
got depressed and killed himself really
yeah i i'm afraid to say that i don't
think that of epstein
i think someday there's going to be a
civil war in the united states it won't
be over
racial lines it will be who thinks
epstein killed himself
and who thinks hillary clinton lacked
him and it will divide among states
but in this case it looked like a guy
who was at the end of the road
i don't know abby the guy
well what's your opinion well i just
know all everything absolutely
i wish i did i don't know i mean
speaking of wack he got a tattoo that
he kept saying if i die via suicide in
prison i did not die of suicide
i got killed he got a tattoo that's
right for me if i die of suicide in
prison but
but but he know he knows from the
epstein case
has anyone ever by not killing
themselves assured legendary status
like epstein if i wanted to be a legend
i'd kill myself and have people think i
didn't
that's why i don't think i i'm not a
double secret pokemon
that never happens it's complicated but
it works
[Laughter]
you know i think we'll stop there well
by the way i just mentioned can i just
mention that walter you mentioned ufos
yeah and could i just say that uh you
know i'm right in the middle of filming
discovery
hit he's a murderer and a shameless
promoter
we're doing an episode on ufos you know
what you're an under
an identified
flaky object hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else